alors alice maintenant tu dois du coca
régime toit des locations supports web
du coq à son succès comme ça je garde la
forme que je reste mais t'as quel âge
car on sait comment ce concert au zénith
et semaine dernière sans la whey du sang
partout mon pad c'était super plein
d'énergie de sueur plein sens du service
et de faire participer le public au
maximum ce qui me plaît moi c'est de lui
faire prendre des montagnes russes pour
l'emmener en enfer notre spectacle
c'est un peu un mariage entre l'horreur
et le rock'n'roll et je crois que c'est
un peu comme d'aller voir les griffes de
la nuit film d'horreur seulement il se
trouve que la balle file mettons musique
ton public c'est quoi maintenant tu
crois que c'est les gens qui écoutaient
dans le temps et qui reviennent de te
voir parce que ça leur rappelle quand il
était jeune à 75%
non mon public c'est des jeunes on
attire sans doute tu vas le même type de
mec qui vont voir iron maiden matthew et
puis les 25% restants c'est quoi la
question des journalistes posent le plus
souvent moins que la plupart me demande
comment j'ai trouvé mon nom tout on
n'arrête pas de me demander cette
question je mens bien sûr je raconte
chaque fois un truc différent
c'est vrai que tu as trouvé ton nom avec
marcel duchamp nom marcel duchamp m'a
quand même beaucoup intéresser tout le
temps mais j'ai interprété un peu
différemment
je crois qu'il ya une grande part de
comics dans l'horreur c'est pour ça que
je suis maquillée
enfin clou une messe un peu complètement
fou c'est pas un clown grohl ses
influents qui a mal tourné et on sait
jamais si on peut lui faire confiance à
sa patrie mais ça peut aussi bien être
un tueur ou ton vrai nom c'est vincent
fournier n'ont fourni et chez toi ta
femme elle tu appelleras sans alice le
[Musique]
plus souvent un appel stupide où elle me
dit et connard tu t'amènes ton père ta
mère m'appelle a dit tu sais maintenant
ça pas grand chose à voir avec vincent
on me demande toujours quelle différence
y entre vincent réaliste moi je réponds
vincent est un cinglé ali c'est un super
simple alors donc à décider y avait les
beatles a prévu des stones qui étaient
proches autant que les beatles et toi tu
t'es dit je vais être encore plus
choquant que les stones c'est ça ouais
j'ai vu la manière dont mes parents
réagissent et aux beatles ils disaient
oh la la c'est beatles et puis quand ils
ont vu les stones ils ont trouvé les
beatles très très bien finalement tu
vois alors à l'époque je sais pas
j'avais à peu près 16 ans et dans mon
esprit le déclic s'est produit je me
suis dit mais pourquoi je créerai pas un
personnage qui réunira et mr hyde
dracula enfin tous les héros du genre tu
vas pour en faire un chanteur de rock et
ça serait le plus grand font du rock de
notre époque et c'est comme ça qu'a
lycée n'est dit quelque chose que tu as
jamais osé faire sur scène c'est pas moi
un truc tout et dénonce
il ya deux trois trucs ouais tu vois par
exemple je m'occupe jamais de politique
jamais parce que bon justin que c'est un
truc plutôt chiant
ensuite parce que ça pas grand chose à
voir avec le rock ça fait partie d'une
culture sa touche une génération de gens
plus âgés c'est un peu pareil pour la
religion tout va pour moi la religion ça
rien à voir avec tout ça tu ne marques
pas excellent non tu sais il ya pas mal
de gens qui croient je sais pas moi
cause de mon maquillage dans les cheveux
mon spectacle du centre
on croit que c'est une sorte de culte
satanique mais moi en fait j'ai rien à
voir avec ça je crois pas du tout aux
messes noires au culte du diable alors
moi j'estime que c'est des sujets
religieux puis je m'amuse pas que ce
genre de truc à mon avis deux spectacles
d'alice cooper c'est avant tout la
recherche du sensationnel toi c'est un
mec qui t'amène ailleurs pendant une
heure et demie dans un autre monde
tu crois pas que le public maintenant à
six minutes à culture et que tu chauffes
plus personne ouais si tu veux pour ce
qu'il est choquant en fait maintenant
c'est surtout une question de moyens
techniques
je monte un spectacle comme ça comme
suit qu'on a donné la semaine dernière
je travaille et que des gens qui ont
participé à des films comme comme alien
comme la mouche alors je leur dis je une
pendaison par exemple il faut que ce
soit parfait qu'on y croit vraiment et
quand je leur dis faut que le pied d'une
micro transperce la poitrine multi
personne de notre côté avec un g10 en
bas tous ces gens là font ce que je leur
demande tu vas en fait les moments
chauds quand maintenant c'est lé moment
auquel on s'attend pas quand je
m'approche avec mon micro on s'attend
pas vraiment à ce que je m'enfonce dans
la poitrine du type alors avec la
technique on peut faire croire plus de
choses quoi ça ça provoque des réactions
bien sûr des réactions négatives la part
des autorités mais
rien d'illégal sur scène tu vois c'est
une limite que je franchirai pas alors
tu es marié tas de mots mais tu dois
plus tu fume plus mais c'est pas dur
d'être alice cooper maintenant sur scène
ma langue décline c'est plus difficile
qu'avant non je me suis aperçu si tu
veux quand j'ai arrêté de boire et j'ai
commencé à me comporter sérieusement
dans la vie
calis devenait de plus en plus fou parce
qu'on fait ali c'était ma seule des
fonds c'était ma seule manière de
m'éclater vraiment et maintenant quand
je deviens ali je me transforme d'un
seul coup quand je monte sur scène
pendant une heure et demie je deviens un
autre look make
et quand j'arrête je suis défoncé mais
sans alcool sans défense eh bien quoi h
en pleine forme nous faut suivre été
rapide quel genre de musique tu écoute
quand tu es chez toi
j'écoute du rock qui bouge j'aime bien
le est vissé sur le hard rock j'écoute
guns n'roses j'écoute lord of the new
church zodiac maille noire des groupes
ce genre parce qu'en fait ce que j'aime
c'est vraiment que tu vois ce que je
skie me fait chier c'est des synthés tu
vois la dance music quoi alors ton père
été prédicateur et toi tu es devenu
alice cooper qu'est ce que tu voudrais
que tu es mots me fasse dans la vie tu
sais d'autant que ces créatifs moi je
m'en fous
l'autre jour quelqu'un m'a demandé ce
qui se passerait si mes enfants mon fils
a deux en un
c'est un petit môme et ma fille à six
ans alors m'a demandé ça m'ennuierait
qu'ils soient chanteurs de rock j'ai
répondu mais pas du tout tant que c'est
quelque chose de créatif employé de
banque
écoute je vais dire dans ce cas j'espère
qu'ils seront heureux j'essaierai de les
dissuader je le redirai allez-y faites
quelque chose qui fera changer le monde
en fait je les découragerait si ça me
semble dangereux s'il ya des drogues
dures d'études de gens là là je me pose
un peu changé le monde
je crois qu'on a changé le style dans
une certaine mesure quand je regarde les
groupes pour qui ça marche maman ils ont
tous emprunté pas mal de trucs à alice
au début des 70 je trouve que c'est
flatteur tu vois moi je n'ai pas du tout
il me pique tout c'est affreux ça te
fait plaisir qu'on timide
bah ouais ça veut dire que j'ai ouvert
une autre quoi qu'est ce que tu penses
états unis du gouvernement reagan
j'essaie de pas y penser quand les gens
me demandent ce qu'il fait peur jeudi
journal télévisé moi ce que je fais sur
scène si tu veux ou alors les films
comme vendredi 13 ou halloween ça
m'effraie pas moi ce qui me fait peur
c'est pouvoir les nouvelles à la télé
toi de voir ça c'est la vraie violence
c'est effrayant et j'essayais de fuir la
réalité tant que je peux et pour être
sûr de ne rien rater de dinars 10 tubes
abonnez vous il m'était impossible eux